the do you believe that this is the
start of the major Russia well I think
the reality is that we have seen the
start already
because we've seen what what Russia does
now President Putin do now is to send in
thousands of thousands and more troops
um accepting a very high rate of
casualty
the most important message is that we
see no sign whatsoever that President
Putin is preparing for peace already to
negotiate uh something which will
respect uh the territorial integrity and
sovereignty of Ukraine uh
what we see is that President Putin and
Russia
still wants to control Ukraine
um and therefore the only way to ensure
that Ukraine prevails as a Sovereign
Nation is to continue to provide
Military Support to Ukraine now there is
now a discussion going on also on the
question of of aircraft and I expect
that also to be addressed tomorrow at
the meetings here in Brussels but let me
add two things and that is that one is
speed
urgency because whatever the opinion may
be about aircraft that will take time
what is needed now is urgent support for
Ukraine is
foreign